[Musique]
l'irresponsabilité pénale moi je la vois
non seulement dans ce procès de la cour
de cassation par la décision la cour de
cassation de de la semaine dernière mais
je la vois surtout sur les nombreuses
décisions qu'en étant rendu auparavant
au sujet de monsieur traoré monsieur
traoré un casier judiciaire long comme
le bras
donc j'ai noté tout un tas de
condamnation qu'il a reçu quatre
condamnations pour vol six condamnations
pour violences dont une pour avoir brûlé
un homme pour le détrousser huit
condamnations pour usage au trafic de
stupéfiants
deux condamnations pour outrages et une
condamnation pour port d'armes
donc en l'occurrence pour moi les
responsabilités pénales elle a été
décidée par la cour de cassation en
l'occurrence mais elle a été décidée par
tout un tas de juridiction pénale depuis
des années et des années et des années
qui ont mené tragiquement à cette a7 à
ce meurtre qui n'aurait jamais dû avoir
lieu si la justice avait fait bien son
travail auparavant irresponsabilité
pénale est au carrefour de deux hits de
deux disciplines qui n'ont pas du tout
la même logique est la même finalité qui
est la justice dans son rôle social tout
à fait essentiel pour définir un effet
qui est coupable qui ne l'est pas et
pour punir le coupable est la
psychiatrie qui est de soigner les
troubles psychiques
cette notion d' irresponsabilité pénale
est il d'une certaine manière
insaisissable c'est à dire
qu'effectivement une société mature
décide qu'elle ne peut pas condamner
quelqu'un qui serait moi qui serais je
dirais dans un état psychique neuneu ne
lui permettant pas de contrôler ses
actes d'accord mais il ya là une part un
peu subjective finalement est dir est
dans la mesure où effectivement l'acte
lui-même à ce moment là il faudrait
pouvoir prouver que l'acte lui-même mais
était complètement déconnecté et à ce
moment là c'est quelque chose qui
devient relativement indécidable donc
c'est une décision de société en fait
finalement lui responsabilité pénale
c'est le fait qu'une société ne se
reconnaît comme respectable que dès lors
qu'elle considère que
une personne appréciée folle je dirais
ne peut pas être considérée comme
responsable de ses actes et à ce moment
là doit être soignée et non pas
condamner pour être m moi je ne je ne
sais pas j'écoutais un des experts de
l'institut pour la justice qui est
monsieur philippe bilger qui disait lui
même qu'il ne savait pas s'il fallait
donner des suites législatives à cette
affaire - avant tout ce que je comprends
c'est la douleur non seulement d'avoir
perdu un être cher pour la famille de la
victime
mais c'est aussi et surtout le sentiment
que on peut qu'ils ont perdu cet être
cher est que la personne qui en est
responsable
n'en subira pas vraiment de conséquences
au delà des philippines pire que je
quittais tout à l'heure il ya aussi un
rap qui vraisemblablement qui avait été
commandée par nicole belloubet ya plus
non pas les sensibilités pénales donc
cet été c'était à commander à des
députés et avocats dominique raimbourg
et philippe houillon
et ce rapport dont on aura les
conclusions définitives à la fin du mois
d'avril plaide lui aussi owen un statu
quo dans le statut de l'irresponsabilité
pénale
donc voilà c'est deguire au delà de
l'émotion qui est plus que légitime et
que je partage le à titre personnel
c'est des questions juridiques complexes
très complexe même qu'il semble et qui
semble difficile de faire évoluer selon
des avocats des anciens magistrats
il faut bien voir que je dirais pour le
pôle a personne pour le prévenu lui-même
dirait on pourrait presque dire que ça
ne change pas une rue menant des choses
il va être à la gaillette va être mis à
l'eau en hôpital psychiatrique je dirais
pour le pour une bonne partie de la
suite de séjour est bon au cc je dirais
ça ne peut-être pas changé énormément de
choses par rapport à la prison mais
effectivement par rapport à la vie de la
société
ça change considérablement les choses
puisque personne divers mois si personne
n'est désigné coupable qui est coupable
et cela ramène cela ça ramène à donc et
ça suscite énormément d'émotion estime
la caisse qui permet de décider que
c'est l'état de démence qui l'emportent
au moment de l'acte c'est ça alors que
l'acte finalement si la sicile a eu un
tel impact c'est qu'il n'est pas
complètement dépourvu d'un sens c'est
qu'effectivement ce que disait tout à
l'heure le le fait alors est ce qu est
ce que le sens était dans le fait de la
personne juive
c'est ça qui est l'enjeu du débat gamme
de la situation actuelle mais là encore
c'est une femme qui est mise par la
fenêtre
et ce n'est pas n'importe quoi ce n'est
pas une table si vous voulez donc cessé
et ça et ça effectivement ça montre bien
que c'est peut-être là quand même qui
demeure quelque chose d'une lucidité ou
sein d'un tableau délirant c'est très
possible
mais comment apprécier finalement ce qui
doit l'emporter et qui doit décider de
les responsabilités ou non c'est très
intuitif et c'est très peu vous m
exactement le curseur je ne sais pas si
une loi permettra de décider d'une façon
claire
voilà